[Musique]
bienvenue dans encore vous une émission
comme vous n'en avez jamais vu avec
uniquement des personnages que vous avez
déjà vu mon invité d'aujourd'hui officie
dans les thrillers et les séries
policières armés uniquement d'une clé
usb et d'un sweat noir à capuche elle
passe son temps à s'introduire dans le
système tandis que le reste du monde
semble taper sur le sien je reçois la
hackeuse gothique
à cause du gothique bonjour
déjà ce petit tombe de rebelles ainsi
montre on sait tous où l'a1 ce sens je
préfère vous prévenir tout de suite
c'est pas parce que vous êtes brillante
et tout le monde fait appel à vous pour
résoudre des enquêtes la détourner le
pentagone ce rush s2games clic-droit
clic droit que vous pouvez vous
permettre d'être insolent sur mon
plateau si tu veux que ce qu'il donne
grognon parce qu'on vous a mis une
disquette hilarants comme vous savez ce
que je vais dire mais j'ai piraté votre
ordi si toutes les questions à l'avancé
pour tourner un antivirus firewall bon
mes réponses dans l'ordre oui non
peut-être non je sonne pas aux portiques
des aéroports et je vais même pas
revenir sur votre blague nas concernant
mes yeux de ratons laveurs et la souris
mon ordi chrome quand il y avait la
métaphore du rongeur c'est rigolo on
vous dit ce que je fous là sinon je me
barre avec ma moto parce que vous êtes
m'ont invité
je voulais savoir si on pouvait les voir
dans les gommettes onglets ou même dans
le dans le passé l'ordinateur serait si
par exemple votre came aurait pas pu
s'allumer et mettre en ligne avant
notamment une vidéo de moi que j'ai
compris en gros vous avez fait une digue
piqué vous savez pu être pire j'ai fait
une vidéo de retour de course dans
laquelle je montre ce que j'ai acheté
dans un magasin de discount
attendez là vous avez clic clic du luxe
de plus n'ont aucun sens mais ça fait
super sont doués de taper vite en plus
les spectateurs adorent le bruit du
clavier donc là je tapais hyper fort et
appuyer père violemment soit rentrée
et c'est ce que vous faites ou non mais
a toujours un moment ça finit par
marcher quoi tomber citerai désormais
moi je fais du vrai piratage là et que
vous voulez piratés quoi franchement
aujourd'hui il a dévié sur facebook avec
des mots de passe tout claquer genre 1 2
3 4 4 x 0 le nom de leur chat en plus de
nos jours tout le monde accepte des
cookies à bâle à regarder vous avez
besoin de mots de passe là on est
bloqués là un mozart des dunes est là
cindy crawford de la toile
vous n'êtes pas s'oublier franchement
avoué que ça a plus de gueule de taper
n'importe où non non c'est pourquoi vous
êtes blasé du cool mais ne chante pas
compris le rapport entre geeks et
gothique par contre quand on passe sa
vie sur le net la seule chose à laquelle
on finit par croire c'est l'obscurité
tendait c'est quoi ça
vous avez une chaîne de riz boxing c'est
comme d'olonne boxing sauf que je
remballer et paquet cadeau samedi
et
le ruban
je suis hyper content parce que quand
j'en veux au napa quand j'en veux pas y
en a et regarder taktak un lot de quatre
yaourts de l'abricot doigt la manche
c'est une version assez mais aussi aux
frais et puis y'a que les cons qui
changent pas d'avis